Steve give us your thoughts on what
Michael Lewis has said because high
frequency trading certainly does make up
a bigger part of the US stock market
than it did just a generation ago some
people say for up to half a volume well
I don't think the markets rigged I don't
think there's a surprise yet piece of a
rig I do think you know as I stated on
the show before is that you do have an
issue with uh necks acute Abul orders
phantom orders that he does bring up in
the book and I think that is a problem
because you go to execute an order and
you think you're going to be able to
execute and it's not there anymore who
gets victimized in that situation well
you know I think a lot we're pointing a
lot of fingers and saying that the
retail guys are getting victimized but
most retail traders using one of the
regular retail platforms of sending in
order to a high-frequency trading firm
or a market maker that's using a
high-frequency strategy behind that a
night any of those guys are using
high-frequency strategies and they're
protected those orders are protected by
the best biddin offer rolls the order
percentage this is not about the little
guy this is not about the little things
it about it's about more of the
institutional but block Michael Lewis
wants to sell a book he's on 60 minutes
saying that's about the little guy
you're saying he's wrong it's about the
block orders I mean why would you put a
block order up on it in exchange when
there's hidden orders you can save
roaches aging over here he likes a
quality of a Chinese executions in
Beijing and Shanghai Steve on
high-frequency trading
look this is just pure journalistic
sensationalism
I mean flash traders are bit players
compared to the the biggest rigor of all
which is the Fed I mean come on
the idea that you know the market is
rigged makes it sound like some computer
is in a backroom conniving to squeeze
this guy or that Steve you and I
remember remember quoting in eighths and
a half's IBM one eighty and a half I
remember sitting you on the floor do you
remember seeing on the floor running
around like this fall but within that
Steve Arthur Levitt who has been a
bastion for the individual investor
forever even he is like you ambivalent
about how important is this Steve are
like what does Steve Rocha and Arthur
Levitt miss about the heat of this
debate well look there's no doubt you
talk about eights and 16s and pre
decimalisation you had spreads that were
wider and the cost to execute for retail
traders and retail customers was huge I
mean I remember doing a trade
late 80s paying $150 for 100 share order
and now you pay less than $10 I mean
that's both ways in the end of JP Morgan
60 and 1/16 yes yeah when we went to
States and then you had to wrap your
head around wait how do I go from a
steam to an eighth understand dirty and
sexist so Steve explain to me why the
system is not rigged well this the
systems not rigged because I think you
do need hft and those buying that's
replaced a gentle meaning high-frequency
traders divide liquidity correct we need
some liquidity in the market you've seen
you've seen the flash crash and you've
seen a bunch of volume coming in the
market the volumes take tapered off your
average in six and a half seven billion
shares a day rather than ten when it was
but what about the assertion that
Michael Lewis makes in his book where
you have companies that provide access
to exchanges three milliseconds faster
and that people will pay up that sounds
like rig to me no I mean look there's
always been a race to zero and speed
with this automated electronic trading I
you know we've been talking about that
in the business for years going down to
zero there talking nanoseconds now look
this is about margins on transactions
not about price levels when you use the
word rigged it makes it sound like
somebody is inflating or deflating the
overall price level of the world's
largest stock market that's just faintly
incorrect when you really when you look
at this Steve and you look at mr. Lewis
is assertions and the idea are rigged I
want to make this Curt you feel as an
investor is it retired for Morgan
Stanley working a full time it yell that
you can go into the market make trades
and get a fair price I think you know if
I don't get get down to the last six
eight or ten to the minus here Tom I'm
not I'm not flipping my stop sir do they
teach scientific notation at Yale I
don't think so
I mean the math of this is what's the
number one thing I need to know Steve
Erlich you need to know retail investors
are getting a fair execution every time
they execute their order they're getting
a very good price at a very low
Commission